i don't see a world in which mary could
beat beyonce in the verses
all those other all those names you
mentioned you want to know it's crazy
there's a world in which they all can
beat each other i don't think it's about
i don't think it's so much you may see
them right no look
beyonce was in a group beyonce got
destiny child back she's not beyonce
what i'm saying is all those names you
mentioned right don't listen listen
listen i'm part of barry's not an
immediate i'm part of this [ __ ] now you
will not marry a legend but she's not in
that not say this while we are in the
same frame
[Music]
obliterate her in a versus battle it
literally would be
not a good look for mary to do that
it would be a horrible look beyonce
look bro bro
i thought
look mary is a legend you know what you
know when you said all those names you
know all those people could beat each
other no but but this is the thing this
is the thing i'm not saying who can beat
each other no no no no i'm saying that
i'm also saying who's in that room
mary's in that room
mary's in that room i don't know i'm
telling you mary's in that room oh no
what's the 4-1-1
mariah's not in that room
she ain't
she's not in the room she's in the room
next door with mary
you telling me mariah carey
and mary jane aren't in the room with
beyonce the room i listen no they're all
it's a room drake is in that room
wayne could be in there mary mariah
beyonce they're in that room missy she
in that room bro
no disrespect to missy no no listen
you're saying all this is all
disrespected you're saying i'm not even
gonna let you get away with the
journalist jay is in the building let's
get it going i cannot let you do this
they are all in that room i actually
don't think
i don't think anyone's in the room with
beyonce